leave it sir Oh leech is a phenomenon
he's 35 years old and still one of the
fittest strikers in the Bundesliga the
Croatian plays four vaults pork who are
currently second in the Bundesliga table
before that polish played in Berlin
zagreb moscow hamburg and munich he just
seems to get better with age but aren't
soccer players supposed to be afraid of
getting old buses tent you don't know
what's the best age for a professional
footballer yeah it's tough for me to say
to me this swear why i believe i had my
best years with Bayern when I was 30 or
just under mine by outside wave oh good
further I see what other I crl love many
players say they felt best between age
25 and 30 what's on cds did I see oh and
i still feel fit and good at 35 and have
fun on the pitch how about no fees boss
over the blood as i said one of the
benefits of being an older player in
evans liga ya see Headley eyes one is
certainly experienced baby fed like when
I compare what I was like a 20 with now
I have to laugh at some of the things I
did give us a new hobby when i joined
bayern at the age of 29 I up my game
Swansea because I can i buy them to get
call me up maybe it's been to my
advantage that I started doing that so
late my form a phony goober fee like
this does feed me does he know spit on
your phone I feel like that thus he
behind for type do you blame yourself
for not having done that before nine
other right now I've achieved almost
everything finish Billy Augustine I've
played a lot of matches and won lots of
titles but now for example I almost
always stay after training and take some
shots on goal fly bit windy she
self-taught windy harbour know I have a
lot of fun doing that and I ask myself
hey why didn't I do this when I was 20
then I might have played at the top
level much sooner
like the new boy Fred I that's the coma
of this pizza foosball are you still at
your ideal weight 86 k let you know yeah
that's yes I have that under control
like maybe it's just a psychological
thing but if I see that I've gained a
kilo or two then I'll automatically go
without dinner dunno tomatis you know
really me albin listen even when i solve
the problem quickly but it puts my mind
at rest and i feel better prepared for
the game there we go with you feeling me
how I'll finish speed that I toss me try
me for hair company where does a
discipline come from Sicily the zia
katia need asked me if I didn't have it
when I was 20 in the other the move
course you have to watch out for many
things as you get older nutrition rest
time to regenerate is also important
that's the second etzion sighs it's out
there we think but that's hard for a 20
year old to recognize every mi least
once again can done now we can be out at
the Disco until 5am and turn up for
training at ten the next morning god
that's like I can't do that anymore so
the full I did I'd be dead for five days
they call me but when young players
reach the 30s or my age they'll realize
how important that is a list of ET de
forest and ocean optics are you looking
forward to the end of your career
they're not having to be so disciplined
ok my globe in the sensitivities does
this minor frog I think the only one
looking forward to that is my wife I
can't think that far ahead I'm still
looking forward to every game I still
don't feel like I'm at the end of my
career feeling me not me i mend a minor
career welcome flash because you're
afraid of the end and what comes
afterwards or do you have regrets come
on us is that a moment we all right now
I've done everything for my career this
the cofe my new career Alice gitane so
I'm not going to say it's a shame I have
to quit Charlie to see myself and I and
us no I've used my time well and I'm
happy another era will begin I'll find a
new direction helping denied it and
Eddie
so when you're no longer going after
titles what then ya feel like a we in
the middle female coach then I would be
fighting for titles again with the guys
thinking and caring for an entire squad
me but we'll see for sure i'll stay in
the sport in football it's my life and
it'll stay my life